今じゃあ肇社長ですストリップ借りたというものが発売されました
こちらですはいいろんなクソリブが飛び交ってますね
あのクソリクが通うだになりました読まれた投稿文に届いた
正しいクソリプを探して取り合おう本当にあった薬ぷ体験カードゲーム
至ってシンプル像ですね等構造に読み上げるいそれに対する[ __ ]
一方取るとたくさん取ったら活って本当にもやってることわかるだなんですけども内容
が投稿文が上の句でそれに対するそういう風牙衆もの奥みたいな感じですね
なんで作ったや素晴らしい発想だと思います本当にもう読ま奴が[ __ ]でプってんだが文化
になる時代ですから本当に変わった時代だなと思います今彼方肉それプっていうのは
ツイッターで何かつぶやくじゃないですかおはようとか
おはよう誰かに対応
してならその馬鹿っぽいリプっていうかすげー小馬鹿にしたような返信とかコメントを
付けることをクソリプって言います私も結構 twitter へて長いので数々の[ __ ]
リップを受けてきたわけなんで結構このゲームに感謝強いと思うんですよねー真っ只中
さっきニュースで見たんですけどねソニックいて結構素の自分がフォローしてないどこ
の誰かもわからないかから来ることが多いんですけども知らない人
がリップを送れなくなるみたいな機能がなんかさっきツイッターでついたみたいな話を
聞いて
終わったまあですがそんなもう消えるかもしれないてくソニックの文化機を楽しんで
いきたいとおもいます
さあというかこの3人で今日やっていきたいとおもいます私 twitter フォロ
ワーって450万人越えを twitter の実績もあるという意味で呼ばれており
ます外れしそうですよろしく
女性こちら相手の御託をはじめ twitter 警察おしい早5年
かなっちですはいよろしくお願いしますお願いします1日の
[音楽]
ブーバーぬーどんくん
っと夢に出てきました他が
でなくすごい気持ち悪いおまんしたからん
そうにやめてくれとここらよっしゃーそれでこの何でちょっと意訳するとかれたやって
いきたいとおもいます
本当にルーラー33で黄金読み上げますとソ連レースで薬ぽ選んで撮るだけでござい
ナンパ
て順番によ見て変わっていって読んでない2人で取り上げましょうね
ナイスおっぱい薬プって何なんでそんなに自己中なの
勝手にすればいいじゃんあっはっあったら見るな嘘をつくなアピールかよ気持ち悪い
をが偽物だろうまず目にシボそして僕とつける可能性あるってことですよね好きです
この声聞こえてたらいいなぁと
ああこれが多い私はフォロー
てくださいあーあおいうわーめっちゃおりするわけねーだろなんか偉そうだな組んだ
からいいね good や面白い私はありませんが顔以外はイケメンだなといっ
よしできましたまずムズイかで結構
豆腐みないとわからないかなさて面からしていることがあって
はい管理の武装黄文雄だけを言うだけではいじゃあ
できますそれができます一般地20代女性の投稿
ふう感じなんだ
[音楽]
わかりんだが別れない
うわっがございます若いならわからねぇ
は別れればいいじゃないとかそんな言葉は言いません
わたしの心
このの底つまりふざけ邪魔じゃないよ覚えてないからください
まあまあ本当に猫さんちゃうんですかこれ
ネオ御茶目なキャラね初回ていいですかそんな通われてるくらい有名時
カッコ30代
男性の投稿ヒカキンさんと言います世の中にクマを言っても時間がスキルだけ
今は自分にできることをやればいいんです
[音楽]
はいっ
顔以外はイケメンだよな世界もゼロっ
あぁそうはいマジで阿部すげー
ん
はぁ
いやこれ日か気になって倒れちょっとあるけど者だよ
一般人男性の投稿でござい20歳の頃
遠方でもほぼ毎日女性を家まで送ってあげたものですがそのおかげで今のつなぎ出会え
たんですよね
[音楽]
はい
これですね
アピールがやの気持ちある
残念では寝ちゃう
店を出てきやもなるんですよね門的ですか
財布20歳の頃遠方でもほぼ前に女性を家まで送ってあげたものですがそのおかげで今
の妻に出会えたんですよね
これなんかだからアイナー奴じゃないんだろうな多分
ピンポイントだもんねすっと1回しっプレーンでますねはいはい
だから何ですか
残念 go 正解は別にそこまでいい話じゃないですよ
これですこれあっはぁああっ難しくねこれねますねまぁいきますね一般人男性の投稿
新機能実装されたのに全然こうしないんだけどなんで
[音楽]
はいはい
しるか
違いますた俺ですよね俺団と違う
パンッ
これですねハイポーしーすんなカス
違います全部残念です
外はこちら4軒目はタイプでしたは
これ解説をついてですけど唐突に個人的な投稿に対していいです茗渓なくソリプロで
いるさあそれねはい4名やタイプといううううっ
これこいつけどメモ用に使われるっていうやー
[音楽]
ブーブー
あったこれ最初とれたの結構やばいよ凄い凄い何でやってだったら最も